carlos compro cinco manzanas que
costaban 47 centavos cada una el pago
con un billete de 5 dólares cuánto
cambio recibió carlos así que vamos a
pensar todo esto en términos de centavos
pues ellos nos dieron este costo en
términos de centavos así que primero que
todo cuánto costarán las cinco manzanas
así que vamos a ver que obtuvimos cinco
manzanas y déjame las pongo del mismo
color verde tenemos cinco manzanas y
cada una de estas manzanas van a costar
47 centavos por lo que 5 manzanas por 47
de cada manzana lo cual serían los 47
centavos nos dará el costo total de las
5 manzanas en centavos por lo que cuánto
es 5 por 47 y bien 5 por 40 son 200 y 5
por 7 son 35 por lo que estos serán 235
centavos 235
ahora cuánto pagó el el pago con un
billete de 5 dólares y 5 dólares cuántos
centavos van a hacer y hay que pensarlo
un billete de 5 dólares por 100 que
tiene cada dólar 100 centavos que tiene
cada dólar por lo que él esencialmente
pagó 500 centavos entonces esto de por
aquí es lo que costó y esto de acá es lo
que pagó así que hay que figurar nos
cuánto cambio le tendrán que regresar en
términos de centavos entonces él pagó
500 centavos y el costo fue de 235 por
lo que basta con restar así que tal vez
tú puedes hacer esta cuenta en tu cabeza
pero vamos a hacerla aquí para que vayas
entendiendo en esta parte de las
unidades y las decenas tenemos ceros y
hasta la parte de las centenas tenemos
un número entero por lo que vamos a
decir que vamos a pedir prestado o vamos
a acarrear uno de las centenas por lo
que al pedirle prestado uno nos quedan
aquí cuatro luego acá son diez pero sí
queremos pedir prestado ahora uno para
las unidades que también teníamos el 0
nos quedan nueve en las decenas y diez
en las unidades ahora sí 10 menos 5 593
6 y 4 menos dos es 2 por lo que el
cambio que hay le tienen que regresar
son 265 centavos doscientos sesenta y
cinco centavos y esto también lo podemos
ver en términos de dólares por lo que
cuántos dólares van a hacer bien cada
dólar tiene 100 centavos entonces aquí
son 200 centavos más 65 centavos y
porque lo separo así pues aquí hay dos
dólares dos dólares más 65 centavos o
bien lo podemos ver como que 65 son
sesenta y cinco centésimos de dólar por
lo que también podemos decir que son dos
puntos 65 dólares a la hora de pasarlos
a términos de dólares dos dólares y 65
centavos es el cambio que recibiremos